jason wright president of the washington
football team
says that there are a set of folks that
have warmed to the washington football
team name it feels like it isn't
jettisoning all the things that we have
been in the past whereas something
that's completely new might feel that
way it's important for a substantial
part of our fan base to feel that this
is a continuation of something versus a
complete reset something brand new and
uh so washington football team could be
the permanent name i like it i like the
uniforms i like the name i think it's
great i think it's fine and uh i'm
hoping that they do it all right i have
a trivia question for you chris to
determine the first pick in today's
draft the best team rebrands in nfl
history question is this
eight teams wore new uniforms last
season how many of those teams made it
to the playoffs all right here right off
the bat okay nfc you got the rams the
bucks and the washington football team
there's those three for sure afc
i believe it's only cleveland so i'm
gonna say four
[Music]
oh the colts did have that little
rebrand you know i looked at them and i
thought i wasn't sure okay all right
yeah what did they do they just made it
a little cleaner like
right yep okay there wasn't much yeah i
don't think it counts as a re-brand okay
i'll take the first pick minor uniform
challenge all right go ahead go ahead
you can have it you sure
go ahead you can have it all right wow
you're a nice guy today look at you old
timer what a nice guy um okay i'm taking
it
okay go ahead old-timer
all right tampa bay buccaneers 1997
final answer yeah the after 20 years of
the creamsicles in which they did crap
they switched to those uniforms they
come out of the gates they were like 4-0
or 5-0 that year it was tony dungy's
second season as head coach of the team
and it just i i cannot recall another
time where the image the reputation the
vibe of a franchise
pivoted more dramatically in one fell
swoop even though there's a lot of
nostalgia for the creamsicles and bucco
bruce
but but
those were so associated with years of
garbage football yeah that making that
pivot oh look at look at look at the guy
in there right and i look good whoo man
now they they screwed it up a few years
ago when they made the the logo larger
they they kind of unscrewed it up with
the uniforms this past year because they
did change their uniforms somewhat i
don't like the giant flag on the side
but i really do love the the old-school
97 buccaneers uniform best rebrand in
nfl history yeah it's a good one i mean
when you talk about going you know from
crap to something substantial it was
pretty big i mean it really was it
changed kind of the the whole
aura of the organization i'm gonna go
with you know something similar to that
a little different way all right but i'm
gonna go with the broncos rebrand to me
that's one of the most special ones ever
i mean they had lost four super bowls in
the orange crush uniform they could
never get over the hump right three with
elway they lost the one with craig
morton at quarterback in the 70s against
staubach and the dallas cowboys you know
just was one of those things where it's
like you know hey it's a cool uniform
but
it's associated with losing super bowls
and they change their uniforms and win
the super bowl the next year i mean
that's they changed it
that year they were the number one seed
and lost to the jaguars right in that
divisional playoff game in 96. that was
the end of that uniform they changed it
next year they go on to win the super
bowl be the packers and you know it's
it's given them a different look as far
as their organization is concerned ever
since
and you know the the sad part is i've
always hated
the the new the new one i i don't like
the stylized horse head i don't like the
numbers i don't like the configuration i
love the old uniform and the best look
for the broncos is when they peel off
the ugly horse and put the old d on the
dark blue helmet that is because
i can't do the old school helmet because
i love that though i wish i wish they
would make that their their regular look
redo a uniform dark blue helmet with the
old d logo i just i that was one that
didn't need to be changed but
but it proved its value yeah
back-to-back super bowls and so that
uniform uh is here to stay or at least
until they decide they can make a lot of
money by changing to a different one the
giants in 2000 they went to the super
bowl that year by getting rid of what
had become kind of the stale giants
thing that they felt compelled to shift
to when they moved out of new york and
to new jersey we're not in new york
anymore we can't have the ny on our
helmet they went back to the ny and i
remember just that look with the gray
pants yeah blue shirts it just it really
had an old school vibe to it right i i
thought that was a great change and
again it took them to the super bowl
right away and they won two more super
bowls after that in that uniform yeah no
it got stale you know the other one
you're right it was a fresh look it kind
of
changed the the the aura of their
organization for a time period too and
you know they they made that change and
then they went to the super bowl lost to
the ravens in that new uniform too so
there was there's something you know to
that
now i'm i'm actually at the point now
where i'm going i'd like them to go back
to the other one i've had i don't know
what it is the the the the old school
rebrand whatever it's just it's worn out
to me i like that old giant's helmet and
of course i'm a little biased because i
grew up that's all i saw and my father
was wearing it and all that i wish they
could do that nonetheless because i do
think there's a lot of new yorkers up
here that love that old giants helmet um
they still do that once a year the white
one white with the old giants but they
need it like you said the original color
it's it's the color of the helmet now
and not that look if you could show that
picture again kristin of michael
australian on the left where it's a real
dark dark blue with the white giants you
know it doesn't look the same you got to
have that dark dark blue the g-man
i wish they'd go back all right my next
one the seattle seahawks the seattle
seahawks went from that silver blue
uniform to
you know i don't know what the hell the
color is now it's a darker blue and it's
a cool more modern uniform all together
but that's one that i love i mean it was
a total rebrand too as far as and
they've even tweaked it along the way
but ever since they changed it it just
seemed like playoffs and everything
became you know they became a more
relevant team the mike holmgren era
started and that kind of kicked it off
to pete carroll and now they're they're
always relevant
next one for me even though it did not
unlock success if anything it was the
pivot point toward three years of crap
football the jaguars ditching the
two-tone helmet they did get to the afc
championship and the two-tone helmet
yeah but they also blew a double-digit
lead in the fourth quarter in that
godforsaken thing they got rid of the
two-tone helmet they went back to the
all-black helmet and even though the
team has a way to go
they need to get back to uh that i i
like what they got back to with the dark
uniform the dark helmet that's awesome
now they just need to get the players
yeah that's right yeah i mean when they
keep it simple and like to the new one
like you're talking about it i do like
it
i'm stuck here i do want to kind of go
like browns to ravens that rebrand was
kind of successful like the browns
moving to cleveland but it's not like a
real real rebound i think i got to go
with the patriots and what bill parcells
did you know he changed it from that you
know johnny patriot who was snapping the
football to johnny elvis on the side of
the head that started it off and they've
gone to a whole lot of super bowls and
everything ever since so he was the jump
off point and of course they've tweaked
it since but that to me is one of the
best rebrands of all time but but when
they went from pat patriot to the flying
jay leno logo on the side right the
problem was the uniforms that went along
with it were hidden not the best they're
better now hideous yeah they're much
better now but uh anyway i dominated
also
this isn't no you didn't this isn't this
isn't a rebrand per se but when the
phoenix cardinals became the arizona
cardinals i like that i just because
phoenix is one type of bird cardinal is
another type of bird it didn't work
arizona cardinals works
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports